me
4を
はいみなさんこんにちはどう努力を向いて
ついてですけど今日はを取らない突っ込み
なさい
皆さんに最初に質問なんですけどここ
会場ステージ減りしの初めて来られた方ん
あれほとんどですねまあなかなかこういう
買えないんで
こういった初めての場所に来たときにみな
さんこういろいろ見ますかでこういう天井
とか見てどういう証明あるんだろうなぁと
か
予想飛びました
頭の誇るボーダーフロントなんですけど
結構いい景色なんですねエコーいった
ところでいい例えばですよもし今
新が起きたらどうなるって考えはあります
か
今地震が来た
津波が来たらどうなるだろうって
想像される方いらっしゃいますかね
再生音2ヶ月ほど前ですけども福島県沖で
震度6今日て自信がありました
11年前には東日本大震災そして27年前
にはこの頭の中ですね阪神淡路大震災が
起こっています
もしかしたら明日自分のみこういったこと
が起こるかもしれない
そういう思い
明日は我が身という思いですね日本中
世界中各地で起こっている出来事っていう
のですね
自分ごととしてとらえられているでしょう
今自身の話しましたけども
私たち取り巻く社会にはいろんな社会から
違うんですね
異常気象ハラスメントヤングケアラー少子
高齢化品後に引っ込む人手不足
めちゃくちゃあります色々ありますそれが
今複雑に絡み合ってきています
私はこのどんどん複雑化していくこの社会
気質それを乗り越えていくためないですね
共感でつながるコミュニティが必要だと
思っています共感でつながって結構難しい
ことですねちょっと説明します
今日感じの辞書で x ことを2つ目にが
あります
一つは他人の考え行動に全くその通りだと
思うと同情とかですシンパシユウ
もう一つは
他人のを体験する感情自分のもののように
感じること
これ感情移入とかエンパシーってはレモン
です
私今か共感というのはえっ
sympathy ではなくてこの
エンパシーの方を大事にしたいと思ってい
ます
なのでこれからの社会課題を乗り越える
ためには empathy でつながる
コミュニティが必要だということ
このエンパシーでつながるコミュニティの
私の経験からお話したいと思います
これらの影響もあってですね結構オン
ラインコミュニティたくさんできました
私はですねを市役所を博すってちょっと
物騒な名前なんですけども
全国のとあった香味が集まるオンライン
コミュニティに参加してましたは他社の
紹介に待ってに公務員なんで普段神戸市
役所で働いています
でここに参加しているメンバーですね
みんな結構面白いつかばっかりで
なんかこう新しいことをしようとか面白い
ことしを社会のために見たいな事をまあ
みんなで話し合う結構心地いい子見てたん
ですね
ところがですねまぁそんな時ですね
2019年
平和元年東日本対数っていう名前をつけ
られた大型の台風が発生します
ここのコミュニティのメンバーである大介
さんて方その方が
進んでて働いている場所その街を大雨
ございます
街全体がですね水没してしまって土砂崩れ
が起こって11人くらいの方が亡くなられ
ています
でその時ですね大好きさんが我々こういっ
たんですね
街が水没してしまって自分の家も
進出してしまった
しばらくですねやっぱり災害現場でなきゃ
いけない
なので他のことはちょっとできない
すまないっていうことで
我々のコミュニティーからですね姿を消し
てしまうんですね
ポランスキーたときにみなさんどう思い
ますかね大変なんすか
かわいそうだなって言うな道場より
シンパシーですねそれを感じますかね
私はですね empathy いう感じな
んですね
で私大時間ですっていうのは同じ公務員な
もし私が大輔さんと同じように自分が働い
ている町が浸水被災してですねそして
さらに自分の家とか家族も被災したそんな
状況になったとき自分ごと鳥栖考えたら
どうもんか私やっぱり神戸市の職員なんで
ば公務員と青の責務があるなというふう
感じてやはりですね好位へとか家族て
ちょっと後回しにして
街のためにですねやっぱり災害現場に出る
んだろうなというふうに思ったんです
でこれは大介さんも同じできっと自分の夢
ですね被災して家族も被災しているんだ
けど
街のためにですねその家族や家を少し
後回しにして現場に出るっていう風に
考えるんだろうなと思ったんですねこれが
ですねいわゆるエンパシーを感じるという
ことです
私はですねこのオンラインコミュニティの
このメンバーですねそういう話をします
大介さんは災害対応できっと大変なことに
なっている
で家もですね浸水してるんで大変だし
何よりですね大輔さんが災害現場に行って
しまうので
残された家族っていうのが一番大変なじゃ
ないかという話をしたんですねうっ
その時にですねまあ高速ニーターパン全員
がですね同じは共通の思いというのを2つ
感じました
それがですね一つはこの公務員だ被災者だ
ということですね
でまあ公務員っていうのは災害が起こると
すぐに来現場に行ってですね市場に
駆けつけて避難所を運営しなきゃいけない
とか
災害現場のその復旧みたいなこともし
なきゃいけないし結構色んなことをし
なきゃいけないですねで再生戦で働く
それがですね皆さんそうですねそれが
当たり前だと皆さん思っていると思います
私たち公務員だってそれが当たり前だと
思ってるんですね
で私たちの家族公務員の家族にもそれを
理解してもらってると思っています
なので災害が起こればですね公務員って
いうのは
住民さんとか住民先住民とか被災者を守り
にいくもんだというのが皆さんの共通の
認識だと思います
ところが一つちょっと視点を変えるとです
ね
今回の場合であれば公務員だって住民で
あり被災者なんですね
公務員の家族だって住民だし被災者なん
です
なので公務員であってもですねやはり被災
者として
守られるべきなんじゃないかなっていうの
が共通のをもう一つ目です
せもう一つは明日はわかっ
今回の大介さんのように自分が働く町が
被災して
一緒にですね自分が自分の家とか自分の
家族まで被災する
そういった状況がもしかしたら次の災害で
は自分の身に降り注ぐかもしれない
そういう思いがありました
この2つの思いがこの場にですね強烈な
インパクト
つまり共感を生みましたん
てい
強烈なですね共感思うとですね割と行動
ってはしやすくなるんですね
なので我々すぐにですね
大介さんの奥さんの電話番
でましてですねどんなサポートが必要です
かっていう話をして必要なサポートを
聞き出して人集めてですね大好きさんの家
に行きます
行くとですね
3歳の子供が暴れ待ってました結構大変
ですまりダンパーして危ないんボクサーも
すごい大変そうにしてたのでまずはお子
さんのお世話を預かるんそしてさらに家の
中でですね使ってしまった花材とかを
運び出すお手伝いをするみたいなことをさ
せていただきましたこれね助けますって
言ったら大介さん絶対援助するんですね
援助すると思ったんで大好きさんには奥
さんの携帯を聞いた以外は何もしてません
何も伝えていませんけども家帰ってきたら
勝手に片付いてるみたいな状況を作り出し
ました
でここまで良いです皆さんちょっと疑問に
感じませんかい疑問というかクエスチョン
ですかねあの私エンパシーから行動を
起こすって言ったんですけど
これってシンパシーでもこういうコード
起こるんじゃないかという疑問です実際に
ですね
災害ボランティアって言ったことは方いる
かもしれんですけど災害ボランティアの方
っていうのは
sympathy で行動してると思い
ます
ニュースで被災者被災地の様子を見たりと
か被災者は困っているところを見てですね
シンパシ道場感じて現地に赴く人が多い
です
say 私もですね実は災害ボランティア
経験たくさんあります
って何度か言ってるうちに分かったことが
あるんですねぇ
災害ボランティアの大半の語ってたせいか
な全員じゃないですね前じゃないですが
多くの方が1回しか現場に行かないです
なんでだろうと思ったら皆さんこう
シンパシー
感じです道場感じてこう現場に行くんです
けども
やっぱりちゃんといろいろやったら
ちょっと美味しいです皆さんあげられるん
ですね
あげるとですねすごいなんかみんなから
偉いねーとかすごいねっていっぱい称賛
いただけるんですよそうすると自分が取っ
た行動にすごく満足してしまって
2回目そこに移行中ですね実はその
モチベーションがなくなってしまいます
それはちょっと作業にも表れてて
方より部屋の家の泥掛けをする
そういったときもですね特に被災者のこと
を頭に出て行ってるわけじゃないただ一生
懸命やりたい頑張って役に立ちたいと思っ
ていただいてるんですけど
パドルを隠してる最中にスコップで柱巻
技術系だったり壁を汚しちゃったり
はたまたボドロ道になったもまあこれは
いらないかと思って吸ってしまったりする
これもしかしてその人にとって
めちゃくちゃ大切なものかもしれん
そこまでなかなか重いと回らないで実際僕
もそういうことをたくさんしてしまいまし
た災害ボランティアとき
じゃあ m ぱしーで動くと何が違うのか
という話なんですけどそれはですね
やっぱり自分ごととして考えているので
そのそこの場所をそのストそこに住んでる
んですね方のフォトを持って行動すると
いうことですよなのでやはり同じ清掃とか
してるんですねやっぱりこの家にもう1回
するんだという思いでへ行ったりとかん
こいつしちゃって大丈夫かなとか
さっきちっちゃくいたけどこの後精神的に
ストレスと固まってないかなとか
またこのステ高く買わなきゃいけない家
直さなきゃいけない大丈夫かなみたいな
ことでですねたくさん方
その人の立場に建物を考えですね
結果
何度も何度もですね被災者仲間そしてその
家族のことを思ってですね
何度も何度も共感エンパシーを感じて何度
も繰り返し行動を起こせるようになるって
いうふうにですね私は思っています
ちょっと災害現場でのいろんな体験の話を
しました
ちょっともう一回社会から見ています
でだけあるっていう話しましたけれども
現状たくさんの社会課題これに対峙して
いるのはどういうところでしょうかという
話なんですけどそうですね
住んでいる場所
何何長とかねになり c とか色々あると
思うけど
住んでる場所に依存して繋がってるコミュ
ニティって言ったらいい形をうずか c
ですね
自治会町内会 pta 消防団みたいなの
がそんな感じなんですけど
そういった地域のその特定の場所にですね
移動してつながる文
そこはですね一生懸命こう今社会からに
対応してもらっていますだけど
人手不足だったり高齢化そして赤い方々
複雑になってきたと思ってだんだんた維持
するのが難しくなってきてですね
1本でですねまあオンラインコミュニティ
たくさんできてきましたけれども
でもその音樂3つでいわゆる工場がないば
に依存しないコミュニティって言ってるん
ですけど
その場に依存しアイコミュニティっていう
のは
まだまだその社会課題にごリアルに対峙
できるところまではあまり行ってないと
思っています
で
そういうこのば25社会コミュニティって
いうのがまあいいわ知見を共有するだけ
こんなことあったよとかそういうことを
共有するだけでやっていると思うんです
けど
それがですねやっぱり変わる瞬間てナン
ですねある条件を持った出来事をきっかけ
に
このコミュニティのつながりを強固になる
まあそれを私は今か経験したんですけれど
もそういったある条件っていうのは
を自分ごととして
強い共感エンパシーを感じる戦体験を
するっていうことなんですよ
で
ずっと話してた大介さんの事例なんです
けども
そこではですね
公務員だって被災者だっていうポイント
ありませんそれで我々すごいなですね強い
共感が生まれたんですそして
すぐに行動に移すことができたんですねん
その行動を映した体験をきっかけに実際
ながらも新しい仕組みっていうのを作る
ところまで行けたんですね
それがこの明日一般車砲ジャスミンって
いう仕組みです明日は我が身という名前
から取ってるんですけど
これはですねまぁ全国の公務員を
ネットワークしてもしどこかでですね
先ほど大好きな感じでのように大きな被災
があっている
町ごと被災してそこにいる公務芋紅実の
家族も被災した時に
僕はですねそれでもやっぱりそこの現地の
被災地の復旧はその場の公務員がやった方
がいいと思うんです街のことを知っている
込みが得られて駄目だと思うよ
なのでその公務員が自分たちも被災して
いるけれどもやはり全力で街のために
働けるようになるためには
その裏側にある心配事家とか家族っていう
のは他のメンバーで助け合おうじゃないか
というようなところでおい仕組みをつくり
ました
さてこのような体験ずっと最後にの話して
ますけれども災害得意のものなんでしょう
かね
この強い共感が生まれるっていうのは確か
に災害時っていうのは生まれやすいと思う
んです
だけどどんなコミュニティでますね災害
じゃなくてもですね必ず
いろんな強化の場面っていうのが出てくる
と思うんです
その例えをちょっとあすみ以外の話でです
ね
私が関わっている2つのプロジェクト簡単
にだけ紹介したいと思います
でゴミである私に
シレーヌ趣味の方から助けてあげてという
ような相談がありましたんで車いすを使っ
ている人がですね海水浴がしたい
ってました
て車椅子って皆さんする創造者わかるん
ですけど砂浜に入ると動けなくなるんです
ね
なので車椅子の方は砂浜の手前で止まっ
ちゃいます
でまぁ彼といろいろ話をしたときに
健常者がですね僕は県除雪けど当たり前に
できることを車椅子になると結構色々諦め
てゆけ
で自分が車椅子の立場に立ったら車いすの
立場になったらですよ
いろいろ秋ラベルそれってめちゃくちゃ嫌
だなと思ったんです自分こととして捉えて
共感できたんですね
なので
彼と一緒にアウトドアをとりかく楽しん
まくろうというな取り組みを始めることに
しましたこれ海水浴です
これが今私が理事長を務めているその
ユニバーサルビーチプロジェクトの
取り組みになっています
もう一つ
アーティストを書く人とかいろんなとして
おりますけれども
アーティストがちゃんと対価を支払われ
なくて
生活ができないアート活動だけで生活が
できないという問題がありました
私は思い出してみたら
アーティストにちゃん徒歩金払わなかった
経験あるんですね
それは知り合いのイラストレーターに
入っちゃったっパパっとながかけるんだっ
たらキャラ作って来ないから
しかもタダで切っちゃったんですねえっこ
れって
アーティストの側からすると
なんだろ自分がこう培ってきたスキルを
すごく安く見積もられたみたいなことに
なるんじゃないかなって
後になってですねちょっとアーティストの
立場に立って考えるとこれはダメだという
ことであの
猛反省しました本当に申し訳ないって感じ
であそこでですね
アーティストに十分な対価を支払える
アートプロジェクト作ろうっていうことで
は神戸ミューラーとプロジェクトっていう
ですプロジェクトを立ち上げて
て始めて自分が働いている市役所のこれ壁
なんですけども乗車の壁に絵を書いてみ
ましたもうちょっと潰されたてないんです
よね
はいんこういった2つのプロジェクトが
動き始めた最大の理由ってのは
私の周りにすぐそばですね障害の方がい
たりとかアーティストの方がいたりして
そのお困りごとっていうのを聞いて自分
ごととして感じることができたんですね
大事なことは自分ごととして感じることが
できて共感してそれを行動に移せるかどう
かですね
で
まあ込み話してますけどもコミュニティの
みんながですねそういうふうに明日は神だ
なというような意識のもとで
を自分ごととして捉えてそしてそこから
何かできる事ないですか何ができないかな
というような声を走って
実際に1本
行動に文でた時にですね
そのコミュニティというのは社会の課題と
か自分たちが持っている課題の解決に向け
た行動ができる強いつながりになるのだ
なっていうふうに思っていません
明日は神何度も言ってますけども
皆さんにとって
明日は分かると思えるような課題とか問題
ってなんでしょうか
一つ一つ自分に置き換えて自分が当事者
だったらどう解決しようかなとか
誰に何をしてもらったら嬉しいんだろうと
いうことを丁寧にですね考えてみては
いかがでしょうか
そこからですよ
私が始めたようなですね小さな小さなん
ですけども明日美ので一歩がですね
生まれるかもしれません
そしてもしかしたら後にそれがです小さな
一歩が
お家に複雑な大きな社会課題ですね解決
できる仕組みに育つかもしれないと思い
ます
明日
あなたに何かが起こるかもしれない
あなたが何かを起こしているかもしれない
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]